[Music]
straight ahead on law on crime daily
the arraignment of an ohio man accused
of murdering a young mother and throwing
her three-year-old in a river while he
was still alive
white prosecutors are now seeking the
death penalty kept the body of naisha in
her apartment on melrose until he is
supposed to provide at a later time
the legal arguments over whether ex-cop
derrick shovin should face a third
degree murder charge in his upcoming
trial
our analysis of the george ford case a
former florida mayor is agreeing to
plead guilty to shooting at deputies
executing a search warrant on his home
and the verdict in the no-body murder
trial
what a wisconsin jury decided after two
days of deliberation
we the jury found the defendant james m
prokapovic
guilty law on crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin an ohio man pleads not guilty to
murdering his ex-girlfriend
and killing her three-year-old son law
and crime's angenette levy is here
with new details from the felony
arraignment for desean brown
yeah brian deshawn brown faces the
possibility of the death penalty if
convicted of the murders of natia
lattimore and her son nylo
and were learning new details about the
way that naitisha died
sheriff's deputies led to sean brown
into a courtroom in cincinnati to answer
to charges of aggravated murder and
gross abuse of a corpse
seeing brown in person brought out
emotions among nytesha and nylo
lattimore's family
listen members you will not speak out in
this room like that this is a court of
law
if you can't maintain yourself your lead
immediately
go head out a man was escorted out of
the courtroom before prosecutors
revealed gruesome details about
naitisha's death
he killed two people he killed natasha
battlemore that was premeditated
he stayed after 11 times in the death
after he stabbed and killed her he
purposely killed
nylo bytemore who was three years old at
the time when announcing the indictment
prosecutor joe deters said brown threw
nylo into the ohio river alive
shortly after killing nyetisha on
december 5th
deters showed surveillance photos of
brown carrying something out of the
apartment building
he said brown kept her body in her
apartment for six
days before placing it in a body bag and
taking the body to the ohio river
leaving it near a bridge over the
weekend the lattimore family and those
who searched for nilo's body
released balloons in memory of the
mother and son over the spot where
prosecutors say
nilo was killed the little boy's body
has not been recovered
no bond he'll be held without bond
pending
trial desean brown's lawyer had actually
asked the judge to set a reasonable bail
but in the state of ohio when a
defendant is charged with
aggravated murder murder with the death
penalty specification that defendant can
be held
without bail desean brown will be back
in court next month
brian thanks ange joining us today is
criminal defense attorney julie
rendellman and terry austin
julie this is brown's first appearance
since it was announced that the death
penalty was on the table
and that he was being charged with the
death of nilo what do you think the
focus will be for the defense going
forward
so i think unfortunately for the defense
they have an uphill battle i think
you know the first stage becomes how
strong
is the case against this defendant
forget the death penalty for a second
how strong is the actual case
the second issue it becomes the issue of
the death penalty because if the case is
overwhelming in regards to the facts
overwhelming that he committed this
crime then the defense attorneys have
several choices one is they can try to
push
to try to get a plea deal to avoid the
death penalty
and avoid the emotions and the length of
trial and then two
if they cannot do that they're going to
try to figure out something that
mitigates the horrific crimes is there a
mental health issue perhaps there is
because he stayed with the body six days
what normal person would do that they're
going to look for something
to try to show that there's some
mitigation i think it's going to be
incredible
incredibly difficult particularly when
we're talking about this poor
three-year-old that appears to have been
put into the water while still alive um
but
let's see what the defense counsel comes
up with yeah terry the plea deal
is written all over this case but
because of that three-year-old i don't
know if they're gonna get it
talk to us about the death penalty here
the prosecution says
they're seeking because of the
aggravating factors well that's right
brian and the aggravating factor here
in this case is the fact that nilo was
three years old so he's
under the age of 13. ohio as you know
has the death penalty
and aggravating factors include the fact
that the individual was under the age of
13.
and the prosecutor said that he's going
to seek the death penalty
no matter what he's a proponent of the
death penalty
and despite the fact that there is a
current moratorium
and despite the fact that the death
penalty might be
repealed by the legislators so either
way
because it's the current law the
prosecutor has decided that he is going
to seek the death penalty
absolutely and and jeannette the
prosecutor accused desean brown of using
an
uber to take naitisha's latimore's body
to the bridge what do we know about the
driver
yeah we know that the prosecution has
said and the detectives have said that
the uber driver has been incredibly
cooperative a lot of people have had
questions about how in the world
you could take a body and place it in an
uber
when it had been sitting for six days
you would think that
obviously decomposition would have
started by that time
and that there would have been some odor
but um we've been told that the driver
of that uber has been incredibly
cooperative
and that desean brown had told that
driver that he was moving out of the
apartment and these were his belongings
some clothes and things like that
it's going to be interesting testimony
from that uber driver thank you all
still ahead on law and crime daily the
verdict in the no body murder trial out
of wisconsin
but first will ex-minneapolis police
officer derek shoven face a third charge
in his upcoming trial for the murder of
george floyd our legal analysis
after the break
welcome back the minnesota court of
appeals is now deciding if one of the
murder charges against a former officer
in the death of george floyd should be
reinstated
derek showman's trial for second-degree
murder and second-degree manslaughter
is scheduled to begin on march 8th
shova's defense convinced the trial
judge
to drop the charge of third degree
murder since then the appeals court
upheld the same charge for former
minneapolis cop muhammad noor
noor was convicted in the 2017 shooting
of an australian american woman
who called the police to report a
possible assault prosecutors say chauvin
should face the same charge
he decided the question in one direction
the trial judge decided it in another
without action from this court a
landmark criminal case
one of the most important in our
nation's history will take place with a
major part of the case
third degree murder missing nowhere in
it whatsoever
that can't possibly be the law a trial
judge can't have a unilateral veto
to block this court's decisions in
making matters worse
that error can never be fixed due to
jeopardy the harm here is asymmetric
if you rule for us and later the supreme
court reverses noor
mr shogun will have ample opportunity to
seek reversal of his conviction on
appeal
but if you rule against us we'll never
be able to charge third degree murder
ever a trial judge shouldn't be able to
do that
and second the trial judge challenged
the newer decision
saying he sided with the dissent and
that's just wrong on the merits
the third degree murder statute doesn't
require proof that the defendant's act
was directed at more than one person nor
in effect
was right chopin's defense argues the
court's ruling is not binding precedent
because of a possibility that it will be
reviewed by the state supreme court
i think we all know as practitioners
that if the supreme court
does accept review in a criminal case
it's often a year or more before we get
a decision
so although the rules limit the time in
which the parties can seek
review by the supreme court if your
position is
the decision of this court is not final
until an appellate judgment is issued
and the supreme court does take review
i mean that means people could be
waiting you know 12 plus
months for final judgment and this
court's
presidential opinion in the meantime
would have no effect according to your
position
um your honor i think that that's the
rarity as opposed
that's the exception to the rule rather
than the general rule
i would generally agree that yes you
could be potentially faced with a
situation
where a court of appeals issues a
precedential opinion
and that opinion does not take effect
for
12 plus months as the court points out
but it also ignores when the state says
that there is no harm to a defendant
especially in the context of a criminal
case
so you look at you look at the context
of a criminal case
yes my client would have the right to
appeal that decision if nor were to be
overturned but he would have to do it
from the confines of a prison cell and
that is volatile of due process
my friend's rule could be the law in a
criminal case
is deeply dangerous as i said it has
asymmetric harms to us
that's one of our most important points
because this is our only chance
today to reinstate that third degree
murder charge we can't fix it
later on appeal and it's astonishing to
me what my friend just said
to to josh larkin in response he said
well the remedy for the state
is in other cases just not to charge
homicides for a year
or longer imagine the harm to the public
not just obviously in a case like this
with the gravity
it has but in any case to say
prosecutors have to wait
a year or more to bring homicide charges
that can't possibly
be the law all right here to dive into
the appellate arguments in the derrick
chauvin case is criminal defense
attorney julie rendellman and terry
austin
terry this is an uphill battle for
chauvin's attorneys
they have to convince the judge who
decided former officer mohammed norah's
case
that a charge shouldn't be applied to
chauvin until a higher court than her
reviews the case
how do you think that's going to play
out brian i
watch this argument there is no question
in my mind that the state is going to
prevail because
the trial court is bound to apply the
nord decision as it currently stands and
as it stands today
the question in nor was whether a third
degree murder charge could apply
if the defendant's homicidal act
endangered an individual versus
multiple people the court said yes so i
think
judge cahill is duty bound to follow the
ruling law and he should grant the
state's request to reinstate the third
degree murder charge here
as it you know relates to children julie
i know you're a criminal defense
attorney but you're also a former
prosecutor
the craziest argument i think we just
heard it there was that from
chauvin's attorney was that if
prosecutors couldn't arrest people for
murder charges of similar facts
until the state supreme court ruled that
boggled my mind
what did you think of that argument or
other arguments that were put forward
so you know keep in mind i mean this is
a defense attorney who's doing his job
um i think he knows i i hope he knows
that it's an incredible uphill battle
he's aware that the murder three is
probably the most damaging
charge in regards to this case because
it's the easiest to prove
against his client and so he's gonna do
his best to try to at least make some
arguments
um before this court now i think he's
well aware that this is the court that
made the original decision in door
and he's well aware that what he's
relying on from the old cases
is really addictive which is not really
um binding
um and i think the court made it pretty
clear unless i think we'd all be shocked
um that the
court has already pretty much made up
their mind that that the murder three is
coming back now whether or not
at a later date it can be appealed if he
is convicted that's a whole
other issue but i believe it's going to
get reinstated
i would agree but either way this gets
decided it's going to have huge
implications either for shoving's trial
or the state of minnesota we're
definitely going to come back and let
you know when we get that decision it's
going to change
how that chauvin case begins and starts
in a couple weeks thank you
coming up on law and crime daily a cold
case solved thanks to a soda pop can
plus the former florida mayor accused of
shooting at police
is taking a plea deal all the details of
the dale mossad case
you need to know after the break
[Music]
and now to check in on top legal stories
making headlines at the law and crime
network
a former florida mayor charged with
attempted murder is taking a plea deal
dale mossad is accused of firing at
pasco county sheriff's deputies who
served him a search warrant last
february
he's also charged with practicing
medicine without a license his trial was
pushed back several times due to coven
19 concerns
prosecutors agreed to draw the highest
charge in exchange for his guilty plea
to aggravated assault he's scheduled to
officially enter his guilty plea
later this week we are waving the
three-year minimum mandatory for an
aggravated assault law enforcement
officer
and the plea will be to three years in
the department of corrections
concurrent on counts one six and seven
six and seven are going to be as charged
and are you in agreement
with entering a plea as it relates to
that
yes a restitution hearing has been set
in the iowa case of a man convicted of
murdering a teen
at a mall in 1979 jerry burns was found
guilty last year
of killing 18 year old michelle martinko
the case was a cold case for decades
until investigators used genetic
genealogy to match dna from a straw
burns had discarded to dna found at the
crime scene
burns is currently serving a life
sentence in a state prison
now up for debate is if the defendant
owes the victim's family 150 thousand
dollars
prosecutors say they wish to
cross-examine the defendant about his
financial affidavit on march 15th
authorities in colorado have announced
the arrest for a suspect in another cold
case
david anderson is accused of murdering
sylvia quayle in 1981.
sherry hills village police say quail
was shot in the head stabbed three times
strangled and sexually assaulted an
unknown male dna sample
was developed in 2000 last year
investigators used genetic genealogy to
identify potential suspect
detectives collected a coke can from
anderson's trash and say they got a
match
her father found her
in the condition that i know she was in
the way that she was left after being
brutalized
and killed i can't imagine
as a father myself
of a young woman about this age to have
a morning like that and i know he's not
here
and for me that's part of the hardest
part
of solving these 40 year old cases and
we've solved quite a few of them now
is that some of the people that want
answers
that need closure they don't get it
because they're gone when we come back
the verdict and what happened after in
the no body murder trial that left us
all shocked
[Music]
next
as to the offense of first degree
intentional homicide
we the jury find the defendant james m
prokopovic
the virg has been marked guilty
guilty on all counts a wisconsin jury
found that a husband
did murder his wife and hit her body so
how did we get here
victoria prokopovic was reported missing
in 2013.
friends family and local groups began
searching for her
i went out into the woods where we
searched
i heard him say you guys are wasting
your time she's nowhere around here
and you will never find her he was
sitting in the kitchen
at the table and he's like i don't know
what we're going to do with all of her
look at all this stuff this place is too
big for two people
it's comments like those that made
investigators suspicious of the victim's
husband
james procopovich but victoria has never
been found
and so the case remained open if you
guys think i need something
authorities did just that in 2019.
prokopovich admitted to lying to police
about meeting his new girlfriend
catherine friday friday was also
arrested for perjury
she died last year before sentencing
prosecutors say they believed the
defendant disposed of the victim's body
in a sludge pond
but the defense maintained she was
suffered from mental illness and was
suicidal
she said in 2003 next time i do it no
one's gonna find me
she meant it she left we don't know
where she is
we don't know if she's living somewhere
else we don't know if she's alive or
dead
then it was up to the jury after more
than 22 hours of deliberation
over two days they returned their
verdict
in the state of wisconsin versus james m
prokopovic
as to the offense of first-degree
intentional homicide
the virg has been marked guilty as to
the offense of obstructing an officer
has been marked
guilty as to the offense of conspiracy
to commit perjury before
court guilty as to the offense of
perjury before
court guilty counsel request polling of
the jurors
we are not know your honor
motions on the verdict this time the
state is moving for the court to accept
the jury verdict
defense position your honor uh we
understood the lengthy deliberations and
will accept the
jurors decision in this case based upon
the jury verdict there is no longer a
presumption of innocence consistent with
the
jury verdict and the extensive exposure
that the sten
defendant faces we are asking that the
court revoked bond at this time
defense argument your honor he already
had a very
high cash bond so understanding the
nature of the case
the verdict of the jury there is no
opposition
court will grant the motion bond will be
revoked defendant will be held without
bond pending sentencing
the defendant is scheduled to be
sentenced on april 30th he faces up to
life in prison
here to break down the verdict of james
procopovich is julie rennelman and terry
austin
julie was this the verdict you expected
why or why not
so i was i was always wrong but i i did
not think that they had uh proven this
case boundaries no doubt i i was
obviously felt that there was enough for
the perjury charges
um i thought the evidence was there i
thought it was enough for the
obstruction charges
but i believe based just on that
statement from the
from the victim i.e that you will never
find me the next time i.e the next time
i try to commit suicide
that to me was the reasonable doubt that
defense needed so i
admit that i was a bit surprised by the
verdict yeah i was betting on a hung
jury the whole time
terry this was not the result you
expected i know that but you also had
some thoughts about how the defense
handled the case
after the verdict care to share well
brian i was surprised that the
verdict came back the way it did because
i think the defense did a great job
at raising reasonable doubt but i was
shocked that the defense did not make
any motions after the verdict and he
didn't poll
the jury and he didn't ask
about the bond he just agreed to
everything and so
it's a little bit surprising that the
defense worked so
hard throughout the trial that he raised
such great reasonable doubt
but after the verdict he just sat back
and i think what
might have happened is they had a
discussion
the defendant and the attorney and they
must have decided that when the verdict
comes back
if it comes back guilty we'll just
accept it so maybe he was guilty
and polling the jury is not that
uncommon when the defense loses polling
the jury you say hey judge i want
each and every juror to let me know what
their verdict is that's not that
rare right julie no in fact
it's not uncommon for one or two jurors
to say uh you know what i'm not positive
that that's my
decision and how could you not ask
absolutely right thanks for joining us
here at long crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
you